Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
nos acompaña merichail serret consejera
de acción exterior de la generalidad de
Cataluña la recibimos en nuestro estudio
de Bogotá en medio de su gira en la que
también visitará Argentina chile y
Uruguay Mary Chai y además fue una de
las consejeras de gobierno de Cataluña
que en 2017 salió a Bélgica junto al
expresidente Carlos puigdemont tras la
celebración del referendo del 1 de
octubre para acogerse a la justicia
belga recordemos que los miembros del
ejecutivo Que no salieron de Cataluña
fueron encarcelados meritxell bienvenida
France 24 Muchas gracias muy contenta de
estar aquí Cataluña es una comunidad
Autónoma de España Por qué hacer una
gira por Estados de América Latina la
verdad es que Cataluña su sociedad su
economía nuestra cultura ha sido siempre
de apertura y históricamente hay hay
muchos lazos con toda América Latina
lazos que van desde
cultura pero también de la historia
familias y que en esta gira lo que
queremos es fortalecer eso esos lazos es
un momento también importante desde
nuestro punto de vista porque en
Latinoamérica se están viviendo cambios
cambios y en no con políticas más
progresistas y queremos también afianzar
esas buenas relaciones de proyectos
políticos que queremos transformar con
más justicia social con más progreso y
por lo tanto hay muchos motivos por los
cuales creemos que esta presencia de
Cataluña en América Latina y en estos
países a los que vamos a visitar
Colombia Uruguay Argentina y chile
digo es histórica no tenemos casas
catalanas en todos estos países tenemos
muchas empresas que están ya operando
desde hace muchos años y queremos ahora
hacer un paso más con presencia
institucional inauguraremos lo que es la
delegación del gobierno de Cataluña en
Argentina hemos anunciado que vamos a
abrir una delegación del gobierno aquí
en Colombia y la voluntad es como digo
estrechar más Los lazos y en unas
relaciones que vayan siempre con ese
principio de ser útiles a nuestras
mutuas ciudadanías y generar relaciones
de beneficio mutuo uno de los objetivos
de la gira también es hacer un poco de
pedagogía tal vez sobre la independencia
en América Latina en esta región
precisamente los sentimientos de
identidad nacional no suelen tener
fisuras Cómo generar esa empatía también
con esa voluntad no yo creo que el
principal motivo como digo es de
podernos presentar como un socio que
busca esa buena relación de confianza y
de beneficio mutuo Y en este caso
evidentemente el gobierno del Que formó
parte es un gobierno republicano de
izquierdas e independentista y no
renunciamos a ese proyecto que queremos
continuar trabajando en un marco
político democrático para ganar
democráticamente esa República catalana
pero lo que queremos sobre todo es
generar esa relación de beneficio mutuo
de credibilidad y de confianza para como
digo encontrar esas vías de de
colaboración de cooperación y que como
he dicho van en muchos en muchos ámbitos
aquí por ejemplo en Colombia llevamos
muchísimos años desde Cataluña
cooperando en todo lo que es cooperación
en desarrollo y en los últimos años
contribuyendo en todo lo que es el
proceso de paz desde 2016 queremos
reforzar incluso más esa capacidad de
seguir acompañando y contribuyendo a
todo este proceso de paz estamos también
con la oficina axio de delegación
comercial hemos sido capaces de impulsar
más las relaciones comerciales también
las inversiones de empresas catalanas
aquí y colombianas en en Cataluña
queremos reforzar todos estas dinámicas
lo mismo en Argentina en Uruguay y en
Chile hablando de Colombia quien sí que
empatizado ha sido Gustavo Petro con el
movimiento de Cataluña fue observador
electoral el 1 de octubre y además es
cercano a xaviventrell que fue consejero
de la gobernación de Cataluña y que en
una llamada interceptada textualmente
dijo si tuviésemos a Petro allí tío
Sería un Aliado de porque sería
un buen Aliado para Cataluña Gustavo
Petro
Yo creo que con todo el respeto Gustavo
Petro es una persona no que tiene su
ideología y
no sé si será un buen Aliado no lo que
sí que creo Es que somos capaces de
tener un respeto mutuo a los proyectos
políticos que cada uno defensamos porque
en menos en nuestro caso tenemos muy
claro que lo que interesa Y lo que
importa De verdad es mantener siempre y
defensar lo que son los principios
democráticos Y en este sentido también
creo que
si podemos no tener esa buena esa buena
relación podremos también
compartir esa propuesta que estamos
también defensando ahora desde el
gobierno de Cataluña que es el acuerdo
de Claridad que es Cómo conseguir que el
conflicto que estamos viviendo en
Cataluña ese conflicto político
tenga una solución claramente
democrática y Que responda al Gran
consenso que hay en Cataluña con más de
un 80% de la población que está de
acuerdo que haya un referéndum para
solucionar el proyecto político y por lo
tanto la puesta del presidente en
aragonés la puesta del gobierno de
Cataluña es concretar ese consenso en
una propuesta concreta que fije como
cuando De qué manera Hay que poder
celebrar ese referéndum y luego
trasladar esa propuesta al gobierno
español para poder finalmente hacer un
referéndum con todas las garantías y con
todo el reconocimiento internacional
a propósito de la gira por América
Latina en el segundo semestre del año
Pedro Sánchez el presidente del gobierno
de España asumirá también la presencia
de la Unión Europea y el objetivo
principal es afianzar esos vínculos
entre América Latina y Europa es este
viaje también una forma de afianzar esos
vínculos desde una perspectiva también
Europea va a haber también como una
colaboración con el gobierno de España
en ese objetivo
yo creo que la
Unión Europea de por sí es una
oportunidad siempre para para
dinamizar y potenciar esas posibilidades
de cooperación en distintos ámbitos Por
supuesto que la presidencia española
nos consta que tiene entre sus objetivos
no potenciar también para la capacidad
de latinoamérica de tener mejores
relaciones con la Unión Europea y
Cataluña como he dicho antes Tenemos
también esa vocación de contribuir a
esas relaciones de beneficio mutuo y por
lo tanto en los diferentes ámbitos
sectoriales sean económicos sea del que
sea ahí estaremos para ayudar a seguir
en esa senda de desarrollo compartido de
Progreso de buscar esa justicia social y
de avanzar para el pleno desarrollo de
las sociedades sean en Cataluña en
Europa y aquí en Latinoamérica siguiendo
con esa relación España Cataluña este
año a finales habrá elecciones generales
en España actualmente su partido es que
la republicana de Cataluña apoya al
gobierno de coalición de España para
esas futuras elecciones de darse unos
resultados similares se mantendrá el
apoyo Hay que buscar nuevos acuerdos
lo que está claro es que habrá
elecciones y la vocación Es que la
aritmética nos permita seguir con con
aquello que ha sido tan difícil pero que
hemos conseguido que que se materialice
ya que es una mesa de negociación que es
un diálogo y una y una dinámica de
negociación para resolver el conflicto
político que ha tenido y a sus distintos
momentos de resultados y sobre todo el
más no el más destacado ha sido la
reforma del Código Penal que ha
permitido suprimir
un delito como era el de sedición y por
tanto hacer un paso para equiparar
también a estándares europeos el código
penal español y que ha tenido otros
elementos como el no la revisión del
delito de malversación y demás Por lo
tanto la vocación Es que después de esas
elecciones podamos seguir reforzando ese
camino de la negociación es sabía para
encontrar soluciones políticas y
democráticas a un conflicto que es
claramente político y democrático y
desde nuestro punto de vista insistir en
que se pueda celebrar ese referéndum qué
es lo que la mayoría de la sociedad
catalana sea independentista o no
independentista tiene Claro que es la
vía es la solución para para poder
seguir avanzando habla de una cierta
normalidad política en las relaciones
nuevamente entre España y Cataluña hubo
los indultos de sus compañeras usted
pudo volver a Cataluña es la primera de
aquel gobierno que también ha
participado nuevamente en un gobierno
Eso habla de una cierta normalidad pero
sin embargo ha sido citada nuevamente a
juicio por desobediencia hay caminos
distintos en España entre la justicia y
la política
hay como lo diría el conflicto sigue ahí
y
como bien dice ante la justicia hay
todavía casos no y hay una una
judicialización desde el primer momento
de este conflicto político y por lo
tanto hay hay retos todavía por delante
para para poder normalizar no lo que
sería normalizar plenamente una
situación
por el momento lo que tenemos muy claro
es que y la vocación y la voluntad que
siempre hemos tenido yo creo el conjunto
del movimiento independentista pero en
este caso sobre todo no el gobierno
ahora de esquerra republicana Es que la
prioridad es no abandonar nunca el
diálogo y la negociación
no abandonar tampoco el proyecto
político porque es legítimo no es
legítimo a defender el proyecto de
República el proyecto independentista
tenemos derecho a no a defenderlo y
intentar ganarlo democráticamente por lo
tanto hay que mantener esas convicciones
democráticas y Aunque no pueda dar la
sensación de que sea normalizado el
conflicto está ahí todavía hay juicios
pendientes está el mío pero hay de otros
compañeros con riesgo de entrar en
prisión por el hecho de haber organizado
un referéndum que en el código penal no
está penalizado con lo cual la situación
continúa siendo compleja continúa siendo
sensible y lo que creemos es que hay que
persistir y no abandonar nunca está no
esta senda de principios y valores
democráticos para para su solución y
veremos veremos Cómo evolucionan a los
próximos meses habrán municipales habrán
elecciones generales luego habrán
elecciones autonómicas
Perdón europeas por lo tanto bueno queda
mucho mucho por hacer Pero
esperemos y Confiemos que a base de
democracia seamos capaces de encontrar
las soluciones se nos acaba el tiempo
Mary Chain Muchas gracias por estar en
France 24 Muchas gracias a vosotros y
muchas gracias a nuestra audiencia
Pueden seguir más contenidos como este
en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]